s'il est encore trop tôt pour annoncer
la fin de l'épisode qu'ovide 19 les
signes encourageants se multiplient dans
plusieurs pays européens depuis ce
vendredi en italie le port du masque aux
n'est plus obligatoire à l'extérieur et
les discothèques ouvre de nouveau leurs
portes une nouvelle étape salué par la
population
ont levé le masque surtout en plein air
je suis tout à fait d'accord pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est le bonheur absolu un
beau cadeau pour mon anniversaire
heureux de l'enlever oui une bonne chose
je ne sais pas ce n'est pas à moi de le
dire je suis seulement heureux de
l'enlever je pense que ce sera mieux
parce qu'à la fin on se sent un peu plus
libre des restrictions sanitaires qui
disparaissent au fur et à mesure que les
contaminations baisse les pays
scandinaves comme la suède la norvège le
danemark ont mis fin à l'obligation du
pass sanitaires pour accéder à certains
lieux à l'exception de quelques régions
norvégienne le masque n'est plus
obligatoire dans ces états même son de
cloche en irlande et en angleterre où la
baisse des contaminations de se poursuit
en revanche dans le reste du royaume uni
le pass sanitaires et vaccinal est
toujours en vigueur tout comme le port
du masque ou encore la jauge de 500
personnes pour les événements salle oms
a rappelé la semaine dernière aux états
qu'il ne fallait pas céder au
relâchement la pandémie n'est pas finie
mais nous sommes dans la situation
unique de pouvoir prendre le contrôle et
nous ne devrions pas gâcher cette
opportunité
du côté de l'europe de l'est le pass and
it erp ou vaccinale n'est plus requis en
croatie en république tchèque ou encore
en lituanie même si le port du masque
est obligatoire notamment à l'intérieur
prochain pays en europe qui pourrait
lever ces restrictions la suisse qui
envisage d'abandonner jeudi prochain
obligation du pass sanitaires pour
accéder au restaurant ainsi que le port
du masque dans les lieux publics et les
transports